[Music]
on this Sunday night Russia's Revenge a
brutal assault to end
2023 this is our new year the Kremlin
makes good on its vow of Vengeance after
a deadly attack it blames on ke the
hidden job market a majority of roles
are never posted online after a year of
downsizing what could be the key for
laid off
workers Plus Will trump Triumph in 2024
how the former president is holding on
to a huge lead in the Republican
race and a royal bombshell the shocking
announcement from the queen of
Denmark global national with foreign
Asser reporting tonight Sophie Louie
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with an escalation of the
violence and the war in Ukraine Moscow
following through on its pledge to
avenge civilian deaths inside Russia
launching a series of air strikes on the
Northeast region of har the assaults
retaliation for Saturday's attack on the
Russian city of belgrad which Russia
says killed two dozen people including
children as Redmond Shannon reports the
ongoing conflict has seen increasing
intensity in the final days of
2023 enena nicotina picks up what's left
of the festive
season what a present the Russians made
for us this new year they are black
souls to bomb residential areas
elsewhere in harke a huge hole in the
side of a modern Hotel somehow no one
was killed but authorities say 28 people
across harke were
injured another strike hit a nursery and
completely destroyed it the residential
buildings surrounding it were hit by the
wave of the explosion Russia claims It
Strike killed Ukrainian security
officials the overnight drone attacks
which mostly focused on Ukraine's second
largest city were not a
surprise the Kremlin had promised
Revenge after a wave of air strikes on
the Russian Border City of belgorod on
Saturday the regional Governor there
said 24 people were killed including
three
children this resident said it's
difficult to know what to say after the
death of children Ukraine rarely admits
to attacks inside Russia security
sources in keev reportedly blamed
falling fragments from Russian air
defense missiles for the civilian deaths
these attacks on both sides follow
Friday's deadly air strikes across
Ukraine's major cities which killed at
least 41 people among the more than
10,000 civilians the UN says have been
killed in Ukraine since Russia's 2022
invasion in his New Year's Eve message
President Vladimir zalinski praised
troops fighting for Ukraine it's
estimated tens of thousands of soldiers
have died on each side since February
2022 one of the latest 38-year-old
vassil medich from Western
Ukraine his relative says she prays her
2-year-old son vasil's godson will not
grow up in a Ukraine where he is asked
to fight and die Redmond Channon Global
News London the US says it destroyed
three boats carrying houi Rebels from
Yemen in the Red Sea today the US Army
says a Navy helicopter sank the vessels
after being fired upon while it was
responding to a distress call from a
container ship owned by shipping giant
MK the rebel group says 10 of its
members were killed or are missing as a
result of the incident H the forces have
been targeting ships in the Red Sea
since November claiming their attacks
are in response to the war in G Gaza
which saw another heavy day of
bombing footage released by The
Palestine red crescent Society shows
Rescuers saving an injured boy from
under the rubble after The Enclave was
bombarded today the Hamas run health
authority says Israeli strikes have
killed dozens in the last 24 hours
largely in Central and Southern Gaza the
Israeli military released video claiming
to show its forces in communist gaza's
second largest city as it vows to push
farther south and take control of gaza's
border with Egypt here at home the New
Year means a search for new work for
many Canadians 2023 was a time of fewer
job postings and increased layoffs
compared to the post pandemic boom that
has many feeling anxious about their
employment prospects but as Ang gaviola
reports there may be some hidden tools
available for those who find themselves
looking in
2024 we went from Help Wanted everywhere
and remote jobs Galore to return to the
office mandates and pink slips 2023 was
a very interesting year because the
pendulum absolutely swung there were
over
250,000 people laid off in the tech
industry alone regardless of whether
you're gainfully employed or suddenly
not many feel job security has vanished
it can happen to anyone this career
strategist knows from her experience in
2017 a bunch of us were let go the rule
was eliminated her advice don't blame
yourself for what happened and set
yourself up for your next role employers
are looking at what you've done in that
break upating the skills talking and
networking volunteering giving back the
pendulum may have swung in favor of
employers so competition may be stiff
but that doesn't mean there aren't
opportunities a survey by business
consulting firm Robert Half suggests
many hiring managers plan to add new
permanent positions in the first half of
2024 as well as hire for vacant
positions there are still hundreds of
thousands of jobs and you only need one
good job career strategist Toby Ola
suggests developing your personal brand
he frequently shares Insight on LinkedIn
and says it's opened Avenues he never
dreamed of my content on LinkedIn has
been seen over 140 million times and
because of that I've been offered roles
that I could honestly not even apply for
from VP of sales to director of sales an
estimated 80% of roles hired in Canada
are part of the Hidden job market the
key to finding your next job or
upgrading to a better role well it's all
about who you know a majority of roles
are never posted online they are found
through networks Ann gaviola Global News
Toronto the queen of Denmark has
unexpectedly announced her abdication
Margaretta II revealed her decision
during a live televised New Year's
address she said she had been
contemplating leaving her role since
undergoing back surgery in February the
83-year-old has reigned for nearly 52
years and is currently Europe's longest
serving Monarch Queen Margaretta will
formally give up her title on January
14th she'll be succeeded by her eldest
son Crown Prince Frederick the US is
just weeks away from the first primaries
of its 2024 presidential election and
the question gripping voters is whether
anyone can stop Donald Trump from
becoming the Republican nominee a twice
impeached defeated former president
facing multiple criminal trials wouldn't
seem to be much of a contender on paper
yet as Jackson prco reports Trump is far
ahead of his
Rivals it's a race haunted by the ghosts
of campaigns past
we're going to very simply make America
great again Donald Trump sounds a lot
like the man who won in 2016 and lost in
2020 only this time around he faces
multiple criminal trials and the real
Prospect of conviction our enemies want
to take away my freedom because I will
never let them take away your freedom
any other candidate in his position
might be considered too damaged to press
on hello everybody Donald Trump is
surging in the Republican race polling
at 59% support his next closest Rivals
Ron de santis and Nikki Haley barely
crack the double digits as long as
Donald Trump is drawing breath he will
be in the race uh the thing is will
people think that he can't beat Joe
Biden that's the one thing that will
break Republicans
off chaos follows him you know I'm right
Nikki Haley once Trump's un Ambassador
argues her old boss would be bad news
for the country and we can't have a
country in disarray and a world on fire
and go through four more years of chaos
we won't survive it others have
struggled to find a message that will
break through with Republicans I think
it's going to take somebody whose best
days in life are still ahead to see a
country whose best days are ahead of
itself TV tough guy
talk may sound good to some people it
never happens Trump keeps standing
strong
even the man once considered his chief
competition Florida Governor Rona santis
is wary of criticizing the front runers
Fitness to serve look father time is
undefeated I don't know how he would
score on a on a test but I know this we
have an opportunity to nominate someone
and elect someone for two terms who's
going to be spitting Nails on day one
Trump's enduring appeal is rooted in a
cult of personality supporters still
believe his lies about the 2020 election
we will never give up they Embrace his
baseless claims that the multiple
criminal cases against him are actually
a political Witch Hunt every time the
radical left Democrats marxists
Communists and fascists indict me I
consider it a great badge of honor
mostly Republicans seem to love Trump's
desire for revenge against his perceived
enemies from Democrats to the media to
fellow Republicans you would never abuse
power as retribution against anybody
except the day one Trump is so confident
in his standing that he has skipped
every single Republican debate it hasn't
hurt him a bit he owes it to you to be
on this stage and explain why he should
get another chance behind the scenes
there are quiet signs of discontent the
influential Coke Network backed by
conservative billionaires is putting its
bets on Nikki Haley this signals to a
number of people that she is really
viable she is the true alternative that
hasn't moved moved her standing in the
polls as Republicans prepare to caucus
in Iowa and vote in the New Hampshire
Primary in January it would take a
political Miracle to close the gap with
Trump he is his party's favorite and
nothing seems likely to change that
Jackson prosco Global News
Washington well from affordability to
foreign interference coming up the
political stories that dominated 2023
and what our Ottawa team is watching for
in
it's been a busy year on Parliament Hill
joining me to unpack the year in
politics are global national reporters
Abigail Beman and McKenzie gray and our
chief political correspondent David Aken
it is tough to pick a story this year I
was looking back and realizing all these
things happened this year that felt like
maybe I don't know they were 10 years
ago uh but everything from wildfires
this summer uh the political fortunes of
the Liberal Party the war in the Middle
East every year is busy always
unpredictable but this one there were so
many competing top stories Abigail I
know you really had your finger on the
pulse perhaps even more so uh with
Canadians this year than in the past
because you were off on mat leaves you
were talking to real people normal
people not who we talk to here on
Parliament Hill what's your top story
for this year it it's affordability no
question I mean as you say I was on Matt
Le there was a an opportunity to observe
things from the viewer perspective and
also you know be in the grocery store in
the middle of the day talking to
Canadians uh and cost of living whether
that is cost of groceries or cost of
housing or people not having money to go
out like they maybe used to do vacations
are a different
conversation the interest rates all of
that roll together is what was top of
mind for everyone that I spoke to and
and what I felt resonated as as the
biggest story of the year uh and
something that also stood out to me was
how the conservatives were able to make
that their number one issue and have
people pay attention to that all year
long uh where the Liberals still
sometimes see seem out of touch with the
average person's concerns on
affordability so through that all we saw
the conservatives rise in the polls we
saw Pierre pov's no actual physical
makeover trying to connect with people
and Canadians that I spoke to seem to
say that it's working yeah really
interesting the way that affordability
connected to both the federal government
and the federal opposition it's
obviously a complex issue Mac but it
really it really stuck does that relate
as well to the top story that you see
yeah for sure I mean there were a lot of
the time that the Liberals wanted to
talk about housing but they were focused
in on the China issue which took up the
bulk of the first part of the year it
wasn't just foreign interference here on
Parliament Hill I got the firsthand
opportunity to go out on hmcs Montreal
warship through the time one straight we
started in Singapore on there for two
weeks and we got to see Chinese
interference when it comes to the
military firsthand we were traveling
with an American ship that was cut off
by a Chinese warship and we saw similar
things like that throughout the year
we've seen war planes buzzing Canadian
war planes and you go back to January
you think about the Spy balloon that was
coming across too so that was this year
too China was heavily involved in our
politics not only when it comes to
Parliament Hill but the military as well
and Mercedes you and I were back here
when when M could not have been more
excited trying to get a signal from the
ship to tell us this news this news that
made uh made headlines around the world
was with the the film that that we
caught and it wasn't just China of
course the other big foreign
interference story was India in fact
India was accused of helping to kill a
Canadian on our soil and the Prime
Minister said so in the house of
comments blew up relations with India by
the end of the year uh India seems a
little more contrite because the
Americans are now in saying India was
trying to do the same thing to a
Canadian citizen in New York city so
India and China the two foreign
interference bad guys if you will and we
heard about Iran too starting to really
pick up towards the end of the year
concerns for irn Cutler's life related
to Iran concerns for Iranian activist
lives um we we've had affordability
we've had International politics David
Aken I know you there's always politics
and ele yeah and list St we had a really
significant uh outcome in one election
Manitoba the first time a first nation's
person is the premier of a Canadian
province and that's wob Cano of course
so I think regardless of the political
stripe there I think that is worth
taking note uh Premier canoe knows he's
the first first nation's Premier but as
you said during the campaign and
afterwards he's trying to uh be the
premier for all manitobans and the other
election of course too is that we had
was in Alberta where Daniel Smith won
can you say a small majority I mean it's
still a majority uh but it was a small
majority I think that's significant
because uh Smith is most emblematic of
premiers and there's more more of them
who want to pick on Ottawa that's that's
their political hay is picking on Ottawa
and to the extent the Trudeau government
needs to make hay on housing they need
the provinces desperately to participate
in that housing and if the provinces
aren't going to get along with the trudo
government that's a big problem for the
government I'm not picking on Ottawa
really did work you go back to February
there's a healthcare deal Justin Shuda
did not want to give a bunch of more
money to the provinces when it comes to
healthcare and on the carbon tax too at
Premier push the liberal provinal caucus
the liberal caucus out there to get the
prime minister to change that on the
carbon tax I think we'll see that coming
next I think we're going to get to that
in just a minute but don't get ahead of
yourselves because right after the break
we are coming back for what is in store
with 2024 with our panel who as you can
see are very excited to talk about that
we'll have the top issues on our radar
for the year
ahead with me again now to discuss what
political stories we're keeping an eye
on for the new year our global national
reporters Abigail ban and McKenzie gray
and our chief political correspondent
David aen I love this cuz it's the
crystal ball I always feel like part of
our review panel should that we come
back and we evaluate your answers on
this which is easy for me well last year
we said there would be no federal
election in the year just finished and
we were correct that was right easy call
to the question of is is that on your
list is a federal election in the cards
Abigail or do you have something else I
think I'm going to go with something
else I think I'm not going to wait into
that prediction for a few reasons but I
I stick with affordability you know top
story for me this this year for sure and
I think that all of these questions and
concerns that Canadians have are not
disappearing you know January 1st and in
the new year and especially not when
those um credit card bills from holiday
shopping start to roll in uh so that you
know that's the question uh are the
interest rates going to come down uh we
see the heads of grocery chains uh in
front of committees are we going to see
any difference in the grocery stores
reports suggest that that food prices
are are only going to go up housing the
liberal spending so much time and energy
trying to tackle the housing crisis when
will we start to see that make a
difference uh I think that's not a
problem that's going to go away
overnight and I think all of those
issues together uh make affordability
the number one story as the uh year 2024
rolls out Mac what do you think's coming
down the pipe well I don't think there's
going to be an election Mercedes
probably because the NDP and the liberal
Supply and conference agreement is going
to be able to stick you look at the
polls right now Pier PV is well far
ahead so if you're the NDP sitting there
thinking how can I get more out of
things how can I deliver my agenda it
makes a lot more sense for them
politically where the polls are right
now to stick with the Liberals try and
extract more from them than say Force an
election and have pure po have got a
majority government which is where it
looks like would be right now so I would
expect things like pharmacare which
looks like it's going to be a little bit
delayed to actually get done and move
forward in that liberal NDP deal doesn't
make sense for them right now to pull
the plug but Mac I'm curious to know
what effect do you think that has on the
Liberals in the next election because
well you can stay in power because you
have the agreement if they continue to
Trend the way they are is it opportunity
to turn things around or is it a danger
well I've talked to senior liberals
about this Mercedes and they are very
confident to have the next election be
on which party is more Progressive is it
us or is it the NDP you know one
interesting thing we have been seeing
recently is that the NDP is actually at
the government announcements we saw Don
Davies the health critic talking about
the Dental Care Program you don't see
that very often so there's some
cooperation right there it' be
interesting to see how Canadians respond
to two parties really working together
in a fashion we haven't seen in modern
Canadian politics and interesting to see
if the question that voters are going to
vote on is who's more Progressive and
whether that is what they're looking for
David what's your perspective on what's
coming for us in 2024 yeah that's I mean
the the pool of Canadian voters 60% of
them broadly speaking would be more on
the Progressive side so that's
interesting listen I'm s to be such a
dull boy here but provinces again that's
for all the Electoral funds going to be
listen we had two elections last year we
got BC going to the polls Again David
eie NDP in the lead there but look for a
redrawing of the opposition map the BC
United are behind this thing called the
BC conservatives so a redrawing
electoral map in Saskatchewan
Saskatchewan party Premier Scott Mo
going to the polls likely to win again
but watch for the NDP under Cara Beck to
improve their standings and I am already
getting um attack ad emails from the PCS
in New Brunswick where there's going to
be one and these ads are vote against
Justin Trudeau's carbon tax by voting
for the provincial PCS and this is the
common denominator in every provincial
election I've seen for the last two
years the country's most popular
politician is Justin Trudeau and every
conservative leaning party Scott Mo uh
the BC conservatives Blain higs in New
Brunswick they want to put Justin
Trudeau on the provincial ballot to
knock out the progressive vote and
hopefully campaign to a win Heather
Stephenson and the PCS of Manitoba tried
that by putting Trudeau on the ballot
with canoe didn't work but nonetheless
the other thing too is we're here in
Eastern Canada if you're in western
Canada you know this the alternative to
any small C conservative party is a new
democrat the Liberals are non-existent
as a provincial party in western Canada
non-existent federally except in DC and
in Winnipeg that's about it maybe
Northern is catching a bit but
nonetheless the point is federally the
NDP want to do what NDP parties in the
west have done sorry I have to put a
nickel in the jar but you get my point
is that is a realignment of is it
conservative or what used to be
conservative or liberal ND the NDP in
many parts of this country is saying no
no no we're the natural alternative to
what used to be liberal parties and
that's a shift well we'll see where it
goes and of course there'll be all those
stories we can't predict which pop up on
the international front as well and
affect Canada and require a response
including things like that inquiry into
foreign interference and and what other
country uh perhaps we'll be added to the
list by that point if anymore thank you
very much to all three of you for
joining us with your thoughts on the
stories ahead I know you'll all be on
top of them and covering them and we'll
be keeping a close eye we'll see you in
2024 next welcoming 2024 the dazzling
displays where the new year has already
begun
[Music]
a brilliant fireworks display in
Auckland where new zealanders were among
the first in the world to ring in
2024 that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm Sophie Louie from all
of us at Global we wish you a very happy
New Year we leave you tonight with more
dazzling New Year's celebrations around
the world thanks for watching Carolyn
Jarvis will be at the anchor desk
tomorrow have a great
night